this is Startalk if the multiverse
theory is true is it possible to travel
to other universes how would it be
possible for us to exist in those
universes if they have different laws of
physics oh that is cool yes so evidence
suggests well not Evans cogent
theoretical analysis of quantum physics
and general relativity suggests that
there may in fact be a multiverse we
have no data on this right now so these
are ideas at the frontier of the
exploration of physics and if there is a
multiverse it means we are just one of
many other universes all with different
bubbles there's an evil Chuck nice
somewhere on another universe I was
going to say that Chuck nice had a
mustache and beard but you got one in
this universe so mine does not so that's
the good chuck nice you are the evil you
ever think of that one did not think of
that okay but now it makes it so much
because they all think we are good I
don't we make so much Hitler saying I'm
good I'm a good man yeah wow that's
funny you just gave me a picture of like
really nice Hitler you know what I mean
in another multiverse is another
multiverse and then the bad people don't
like him cuz he's nice exactly exactly
so so each of these universes would have
it's likely that they would have a
slightly different laws of physics okay
perhaps a different charge on the
electron a different gravitational
constant the gravitational constant is a
is a is a is a it's a term in the
equations of gravity that Isaac Newton
first wrote down okay and it tells you
it's a measure of how strong gravity is
relative to other forces in the universe
if those are slightly different and you
got a ticket to that universe mm-hmm I'm
sorry sorry for you yeah yeah right
things are going to work out very well
for you you they will not end well they
will not at Landover so you really do
need a universe with the same laws of
physics because the very forces that
bond the molecules and atoms in your
body
rely on the values of the laws of
physics that are in our unit
right so yeah yeah you don't you send
something else into that universe to
check it out first right like what you
know
what's-his-face the little robot I
forget now I'll forget it what was the
little robot uh which robot you know
another Steven Spielberg robot and the
world had been destroyed Rowley Wow
we're gonna send wall-e send Wally and
Wow I have a better idea send one of the
crash-test dummies
that'll work they cool with it damn it
this is a kind of thing they die every
day every day